done would you say if putting the
philosophy is
speaking wouldn't you say that it's true
that whereas secular states may
establish freedom of religion religious
states are not likely to establish
freedom of secularism yes
synchronization is I mean so the process
whatever separation of church they said
begins within religion itself it begins
I mean it gets a massive move forward
within the city well because of the core
the whole issue of the religious wars of
Europe is one part of in the sixteenth
century where you suddenly have this
situation that had not existed
previously in which peoples are being
pulled apart I mean people's who
otherwise had work of commonality of
that but by the fact that you know in
this territory there's a prince here and
that turd and of course the people were
forced to follow the religion of the
prince so this is where you begin to get
the evolution of this idea that what
religion people follow should not be as
it were in accord with what political
regime obtains now that of course that
lesson can be learned not only in the
context of religion but in the political
sphere as well and I think again one of
the things that I think is a starts like
terror I look in the last month as you
know in the United States and I suppose
to some extent this has been covered
here we've seen eruptions of intolerance
on university campuses right and what
we've seen is a kind of new fascism
right where the language now is this we
must create a safe space and the safe
space is one in which nothing can be
contested right now it seems to me that
is a kind of new theocracy it's a new
attempt to try to define a space within
which an ideology which is will actually
cover every aspect of thing or by
calling it a new theocracy you're making
a very damning admission it would be an
it would be a damning a mission to find
guru himself an advocate feel the
critical fuel I would like to ask you
Michael why say that you have so much
faith in science and technology to make
our world a more civilised world
well it's not faith it's confidence in
the fact that it's done so well so far
so for example secular states really do
do better than a more religious state so
you just take the rates of religiosity
church attendance belief in God across
20 industrialized nations for this
success and the more and the more
religiosity you have in a country the
worse it does and by worse I mean STD
rates abortion raids crime rates
homicide rates and so on the secular
states of northern Europe are the safest
places they have the lowest teen
pregnancy rates they have the lowest
homicide rates America you know we are
the most religious of the top twenty
industrialized Western nations and we
have the highest rates of these social
ills come on relation causation
homicides are conservative Christians
argue in America that we need religion
to keep people in check to keep their
moral values safe and so forth I'm a
secular person but actually I think the
evidence shows that by many different
measures of course terrible things have
done in the name of the rigid I don't
deny that for a second no I'm chance to
talk okay but it's also true that if you
look at data religious at least in the
United States people who are Mormon this
is a secular person speaking people who
are more religious controlling for many
other things are in fact nicer they're
more likely to help old ladies across
the street they're more likely to give
it to charity including secular
charities they're more likely to worry
about underprivileged people than other
people are so let's I'm sorry can I just
finish my sense I don't like to have a
discussion about this issue of the role
religion in which we have it's either
religion is the great evil in the world
or religion is a great good in the world
the fact is empirically there's some
good I'm not even sure it's a watch but
there are some good things about
religion and in this argument I'm gonna
try to defend that side because I if we
were if I were in a different group of
all theologian all actually religions
can do some bad things but I'm trying to
get a little bit unbalanced countries
I'm doing cross country comparison now
it's but it doesn't say think about
what's causing bad but Michael Corbitt
who sounds into geography because I
still yeah okay well so that the idea
that the Enlightenment that we can
reason our way to certain concepts that
work better than others like rights
expanding
civil rights and civil liberties to more
people is better for a society it makes
it more prosperous there's more freedom
there's more justice and so on that was
invented in the Enlightenment
essentially it's not or at least it's
also not true we had an earlier frame
here in which we had the good reason and
the bad passion that's a classic trope
from Western history that's simply not
true let me give one specific example
people all over the world were
emotionally moved by the boy on the
beach that was not an intellectual thing
it wasn't the people sort of thought to
themselves well is this gonna be bad for
me or good for me
you saw the kid in the surf and you
thought that's wrong and that was a
moral intuition that came before
subsequent ration rationally rationally
analyzed well what do we do about it
should we do should there you do it it's
it's just not right to have this simple
idea that I'm a rationalist too but it's
not right and I don't know if this was
your view to think well anything is
passion-driven is wrong that's not right
passion can drive great things yeah and
just one sense until they're translated
into compelling arguments in other words
what I'm saying you don't you don't even
need argument so I take it the point
here is that what little sis here is not
the sense that that child or in any
other given case has rights it's that
they have needs right it's the
recognition of human suffering and that
doesn't need to be mediated by any
argument right then that's that's why
this universality can rest in some
question is an Sensibility the question
is asked which we've tried to get it
asked for the last four years
why should America or why should the
West do anything to help the Syrians
perfectly good question right one an
answer that certainly is not going to
answer that question is because many
people are outraged by what's happening
there because we know from this example
that outraged when it's not connected to
action is a very common phenomenon yes
right so the only way to do it is to
move it you may begin with a passion or
an outrage but then I believe you have
to then translate or your passion
into something that other people can
recognize and and that's the business of
argument and the business of argument I
believe in the largest trust general
sense yet then you're in the business of
publicly yeah absolutely well I am
seated here next Tunisian colleague and
two Egyptian correct if and I am Israel
if we could take religion out of our
lives they would think to change
completely I am NOT speaking I am NOT
talking about metaphysics upon religion
and politics if we religious politics if
we could get rid of it believe we can't
an eternal peace would be installed in
the Middle East and around the military
just to watch to emphasize what you just
said religion and again I in a sense
agree with everybody with with both
sides argument in the sense that yes yes
no honestly religion is important very
important to some people and not
important to others I think it's a very
few yes it's a personal choice okay some
people can be religious some people
don't need to be religious but to get
religion in the context of politics is
bad it's very bad it's bad for for the
system for politics for the human beings
it's bad for religion just one never as
a Jew I belong to the people who
invented monotheism okay I'm not proud
of it you know just imagine what a
wonderful world would be living if the
gods of the Greeks have won the battle
but it's a place we Walter have been but
we are monotonous with morality but we
must we must try
really we must try to by the force of
reason to liberate ourselves of what
religion has done these things still
doing to our region into our peoples and
that as the sooner the better
you